um golaço ao em 32
como vai o ganho judicial de quem fala é
dar que exige muito bem vindos
a mais velha e um estrago de você já
sabe que está dentro desta linha não
parece atacar fora o ditado de que mais
um vídeo do laser é essa ele é eu sua
hoje nós vamos fazer sim encontro
desculpa mas é mas eu tenho que chegar e
eu encontrei tipos três primeiros muito
loucos com leve outros dois já tenta
inventar a minha maneira mas acho que
vai dar uma coisa muito louca mesmo
então foi só até o fim só vai ser muito
louco pra quem já você pipoquinha
qualquer coisa primeiro e vamos lá então
os primeiros mas antes o pessoal quer
destruir uma coisa muito importante
muito importante esse dezembro que
tentará encostar em um vídeo por dia
aparecido grosso vai ser muito doloroso
falar muito porque elas pedir muito
liquidez filho porque motiva muito mesmo
de hoje já vou ter aquela força que ela
força postar um vídeo por dia eu preciso
mesmo disso tocou com você só você acha
que eu já tô participar e peraí peraí o
hábito de fumar que já sabem que não
foram inscritos aqui no canal em
escrevam ea tv identificações para não
perderem nenhum vídeo é agora pessoal
para lá então os 5 truques colégio eu
não sou o primeiro truque com os
reservas em um experimento usando água
coisa daqui mas isso não faz nada ou
mais e não faz nada na água tirar quase
num carro de sua mãe possa estar a
pensar eu não vou tentar procurar água
colégio nós é impossível se bem que
sabemos pressionou mas não isso não é só
porque eu vou tentar fazer aqui é usar a
água como o espanhol sabe que vocês vão
lá no meio da rua e paraná está na mão
de vocês vem aquela profissional bem
grande e você já não possui 1.000 deus
tem uma pessoa igual a mim é especulação
e vai ser muito boa porque a água vai
ter toda a luz do laser e vamos ver o
que vai acontecer embora lá não só aqui
na casa de banho e eu até cheguei um
pouco de luz propostas precisam ver isso
muito bem mas não fazer com que o nosso
primeiro
e para isso é preciso tomar um copo do
fim que ir eu estou aqui é muito simples
eu apenas preciso fazer confira aqui no
copo e este caso mas que já foi nem de
food service for sempre e quando existir
um copo de água sem um fio de água
quando fhc eo rio e porto novo de ajudá
lo e ajudá lo eu acho que deixei que são
bastante porque eu já estava prometida
agora ainda mais prático mas acho que dá
pra fazer e depois deixamos um copo com
água é só apontar nosso mais eurocopa e
vamos ver o que vai acontecer quando
vamos passar pelo buraco e é isso que
nós vamos ver para lá pessoal to que
encher um copo com água filho de deus
acho que eu gosto daqui mas com ele e
estragando o corpo não pode ser não você
for usar tudo isso busca-se uma tecla
silva foi morto porque eu estou aqui e
espero que esta sofreu no rio só não tem
mais corpo e precisa mesmo ser um copas
em parceria extraordinária da iii só
podem ver daqui uma mini fonte de água e
um fio de água estava incluído o empate
muito menos o tamanho fluido é ter uma
cascata igual a 32 o vai e olha só
calmas e tem mais o pessoal vai tentar
passar pela água
olha aí está aqui na minha mão muito
louco aqui por fita do mundo é mau mas
agora está usando
o serviço funciona mesmo agora talvez
porque são mais científica nem pessoal
tá aconteceram final no chamado total
interno reflexo em inglês que eu tenho e
falo em lei em português significa campo
eleição interna total mas é um evento
que acontece é toda a luz do laser é
entrar dentro do que um fio de água e
começar a refletir tempo nas paredes da
água e vai tudo abaixo até tocar na
minha mão eu vou te dar um exemplo com
essa ilustração que vai aparecer aqui é
que não é só ela nos foi toda por isso
que aconteceu dentro do que o fio d'água
é muito para lá então pessoal segundo
truque é que golaço e este a explosão é
este truque é que eu preciso preciso
laser obviamente sem truques com o eder
é uma ser um isqueiro e cinco velas é eu
acho que você já não era o que eu vou
fazer né isolado que vai acontecer é que
há muito mas vai ter o poste dos quero
consequentemente abrir um buraco mesmo
buraco vai ser tudo gastos quero ea
velas quando você está à frente do
isqueiro
mas por enquanto sei o que é muito bom
ver essa explosão quebrou a fazer isso
agora eu só preciso posicionar assim as
minhas velas
acho que assim as 15 00 ea e deixar eu
espero que não mas se eu gastei por
qualquer lado tem lá sempre uma vela
então vai explodir que isso que só que
tal não foi legal agora só deixá lo aqui
vou cortar um pouquinho e agora é só
apontar para o nosso quero só ver o que
vai acontecer em 3 2 1
olha aí já a fumaça se a lei vai voltar
para lá pessoal a en 321 afasta porém já
sem fumaça
ai ai ai
vocês viram o que aconteceu como assim
como não excluiu o v
felizmente encontrei mais um isqueiro e
isso é ótimo estar aqui na casa de bola
3 2 1
espero que funcione em bora bora bora só
mais uma coisa
a justiça aconteceu lenço na boca futuro
da coisa pública como é que é possível
não fica assim
eu só vejo eu sou como ficou o nosso
canto tudo discutido só volta à i
vocês viram o que aconteceu só a série
foi muito louco mesmo mas mais do que
ainda é o terceiro colégio é só aparecer
truque é usar uma arma e vou colocar o
meu mas em cima dela e com isso nós
vamos fazer aquelas armas muito potentes
sabem que os pepinos espanhóis haviam
nunca falei porque eu sei que é um laser
que ajuda sempre mirar na então eu vou
tentar fazer isso mas isto é tem uma
particularidade estou a dizer para onde
ia ajudar na pontaria e vai ajudar
também a destruir o nosso alvo porque o
keima imagine só tenho uma arma como
base deste problema meu é muito louco eu
vou tentar fazer isso vou colocar aqui
luiza e vamos ver o que conseguimos
fazer com ele ontem se colocar muita
silva até prejudicar banco lar para 8 de
estar aqui nossa arma laser 31 vai
funciona e agora será queimada 321 e
agora vamos encher um balão com ela
olha só vai ficar mais interessante
ontem que uma compra a nossa arma é lei
está muito louco e eu vou mostrar a
filmagem daqui eu não sei porque nosso
grupo pega muito mais europa e só em 321
lei seca muito acentuada aqui na go pro
olho e isso nos fica muito louca e agora
nós vamos tentar aguentar alguns balões
com o curso aqui no quadro uma nova
ficar aqui sou assim caiu 5 balão vai
ficar aqui com um lado agora aqui para
lá eo pessoal já que ligou pra filmar
uma lei que está a filmar também preso
bacana né
e mais o meu deus
sua vítima tudo muito bem mas para lá só
pro 4 é e 14 que é muito parecido mas em
vez de termos a pistola vamos ter um dom
o que eu vou fazer é muito simples é só
tomar umas e conseguiu bater no tronco
depois disso é só retirar alguns balões
colher aqui pelo quarto ou pela casa
mesmo tempo nós ainda e vou tentar
levantar o dom de dentro de casa e
enfrentar os bolões eu não posso fazê lá
fora isso agora porque há muito vento
então é para lá que os trilhos tron e
asa da obra mas o o olfato muito vento
ai ai ai
a época é só vocês viram isso
é um grupo difícil não é mas você
perguntar a ajuda só vai ser passar
completamente por cima da câmera o que
quer dizer que já vazou para um
pouquinho além disso
[Música]
o show the hills por dilma é uma escola
com a lusa tentou hoje é o último do eca
é simples em cima disso porque o pessoal
é só substituir jamelli se está tudo bem
pra deus
[Música]
olha eu já tava tão bom
o wow é e aí apoio tudo olha isso porque
o maior destaque outra aqui outra aqui
eu acho que já não tenham substituído as
suas vantagens a gol é tão pessoal pro
nosso quinto e último encontro e este é
outro que eu mais goste porque só porque
o da leitura traz uma curiosa aqui o
oakley e nike muitos prédios pequenos
desde o que eu vou fazer é usar o poder
mas a tal como eu fiz naquele sofrimento
da água vai ter um exército através do
fio de água eu vou tentar fazer isso mas
com os pandits vou tentar usar uns cinco
ou seis pães rio vários mas até o balão
se na que o pé da força a quem diz fica
força continuar a alimentar o balão é
isso mas universal e se isto der certo e
teve uma grande idéia e sisters e não
mas só se der certo vou tentar espalhar
spam disputou na casa eu vou tentar
roubar o raio laser desde a minha casa
do bairro tá aqui traz até a cozinha lá
embaixo e vamos vencer um evento um
balão imagina só tipo 2030 para dentro
de casa e uma semana passada em toda a
casa mas fazia muito louco só querem ver
esse vídeo que no final deixei muito
light sério acho que vou fazer meu ser e
eu quero muito fazer esse filho mas só
deixaram muito light mas antes disso
para lá desse experimento mais simples
funciona de fato embora lapso absolvida
primeira reflexão
bora lá em 321 bike
olha isso aqui já o west brom só podem
ver posso controlar o laser para
qualquer direção olha está muito louco
até pessoal tá tudo pronto e imediato na
posição certa e agora vou pagar a luz e
feijão sol e foi 31 que vai
só aqui dentro do nosso mais até que
temos 1 234 expandir ou seja vai passar
por quatro expandido e finalmente nós
temos nosso bolão eu sei os perfis do
twitter fernando alonso segundo eles vai
lá só em 32 vai ou o início o que o
burrito núcleo de ai meu deus
ae eu estou cansado é este vídeo não foi
só o experimento foi sem sofrimento sem
um vídeo é do tipo 4 o trabalho de cinco
vídeos mas é esse pessoal eu adorei
fazer essa experiência espero que vocês
também têm conquistado aqui há que se
quiser ver mais vídeos com laser como
entende como é que as coisas que queiram
vir aqui no canal que eu vou postar um
vídeo por dia agora em dezembro o
documento em toda a experiência que
vocês queiram ver aqui e ainda por cima
do oscar muitas encomendas agora então
tudo o que vier eu vou fazer em gravatá
pessoas que tenham estado já sabe
investir muito laquê neste vídeo isso
nós aqui no canal em schruns que nunca é
demais nunca é demais não taxar os 4
milhões para quem sofre quem vai até a
próxima
[Música]